I want to tell you this if you can't
acknowledge that another dude is
good-looking you'll never convince me
that you don't want to that
dude there you will never convince me
I'm GNA tell you right now if you are so
upset if somebody being gay upsets you
so much that you get angry you're angry
that you want to that dude that
might be true I don't think there's any
doubt dude so just open your arms dude
let it in
yeah yeah we're not well I mean yeah
we're not asking you to open your butt
and let it in it's just we're just
asking if you want to yeah no how to
knock it out yeah yeah only if you have
to you don't have to nobody's forcing
anal on anybody I can hear in the
comments already hey
Gaylords the homos there's no need to
get anal about it